[Music]
this scene from women talking takes
place in a hay loft where a group of
women gather to discuss what they are
going to do and how they're going to
respond after a series of violent
attacks in their Community men and women
would make all decisions for the colony
collectively
women would be allowed to think
girls will be taught to read and write
they take on everything including their
relationships to each other but they
have a very short window to make this
decision in the men have left the colony
they're going to be back within a day so
there's this enormous tension of having
to come to this giant decision with all
of these philosophical and ethical
issues attached to it the women of the
colony that we meet in this Gathering
they've all suffered something almost
unspeakably horrific and they are all
dealing with it in their own particular
ways dictated by their own temperament
the schoolhouse must display a map of
the world so that we can begin to
understand our place in it well I really
loved about this scene is that it
explores one that's often not spoken
aloud it's kind of in an emotional way
something that they translate with each
other the women have three choices they
can stay and forgive they can stay and
fight or they can leave and because they
aren't all on the same page this
discussion is so important
a new religion taken from the old but
focused on love
would be created by the women of the
colony
our children would be safe
collectively
[Music]
you sound like August's mother
Sarah is enormously well prepared she
broke down every scene she went through
every shop she talked about how she was
going to cover it yeah saying at the
same time you could do this yeah do you
like them yeah
the first Halo I've seen we did 150
times over two days like nine pages of
dialogue which I've never done we were
all in this very strange room together
all the time where we didn't really see
the outside world and I do think we went
slightly mad
it's nine actors in a room going through
Heaven and Hell together that to me
feels a bit unprecedented that level of
commitment and intensity it was sort of
inconceivable until we got here
this is from beginning to end just
probably wants to uh reset the paper but
then we kind of honed in on ways we
could make that more workable
for Consuelo it's really will obviously
be coming into this a lot so we'll just
keep going okay it was many many takes
because the camera was on each person
and there were nine of us so nine times
and however many angles that's a lot of
takes everybody's point of view is huge
on their own but to actually allow that
debate and allow that vulnerability and
allow that strength and the conviction
and the unknown evolve to let these
extraordinary women like Claire and
Rooney and Judith and Sheila and
Michelle step into that space was what I
think Sarah enabled I don't know you're
a dreamer
where women without a voice
we have nothing to return to even the
animals are safer in their homes than we
women are
all we have are our dreams
so of course we're dreamers
it was so fascinating watching the
actors just seeing how hard they work
and the commitment to this story
the casting process took almost a year
there were so many people who could have
potentially played every part but it was
also finding the chemistry and the
Alchemy between them everybody cared
about this project and that level of
care they brought established this
atmosphere of respect the most important
thing that I would want to say about
this cast is that they are an ensemble
they sit in a different place not just
because of their age as women but also
because of their experience as actors so
they kind of ground the stylistic
choices that Sarah was making in the
room
and you want to hear my dream
[Music]
I dream that people who speak nonsense
who have no grasp on reality are not put
in charge of making statements it was a
very intense experience we all knew each
other's lines like the back of our hand
that we knew what had happened in that
room
we never left each other it was a
community and I think by putting us
together and having us form our own
bonds with each other in addition to the
ones you were creating within our roles
it really helped amalgamate the
characters into the story and bring some
real truth to life moments
what if the men refused to meet our
demands
[Music]
we'll kill them
no oh no
Sarah talked to me a lot about the
weight of this decision that these women
are about to take who always talk to me
about how epic he wanted this decision
to feel visually but also still not shy
away from the intimacy
how do we do this and over yeah it makes
a lot of sense
there's no real use of here in doing
that no I just do it this way more
Dynamic thank you for that we spend
months together talking about the film
looking at images creating images
thinking about how we can create
something specific to each film Sarah
and Luke chose to keep a lot of people
in one frame and I think that that was a
really interesting way of telling the
story so that you always felt the
presence of other people
that Barn was extraordinary it was a
work of art Peter Costco didn't just
construct the hay loft technically in a
way that was easy to film in he made it
a place that held that debate we
originally starred here in a darker more
secluded place but as they begin to take
control of this space and take control
of their lives these doors and windows
get opened up to reveal the outside
world there was this tendency to want to
make the barn more of an enclosed
smaller space Sarah and I talked about
going the exact opposite than that
because you want to feel more like
they're almost Reinventing their faith
so we had this idea with Peter to make
the Loft more like a cathedral I thought
of a different kind of trust system that
we were able to build that made our
interior sets a lot more manageable to
shoot in we had two columns in The
Hayloft space so that gave Sarah and
Luke a lot more freedom Peter's work was
material is an incredibly skilled Elder
and he was embracing and inhabiting the
characters as he created their spaces
what if the men who are in prison are
not guilty
mother oh Chad yeah are you asking we
caught one of them
I saw him but only one he's only one but
he named the others for what if he was
lying
we must consider this no
no that is not our responsibility
because we aren't in charge of whether
or not they are punished
so I really put so much time and energy
into who was not just in that Hayloft in
terms of the actors but like every crew
member every head of Department she
cultivated like such a group of people
that made it possible for us to make
this thing yeah so what's a way we could
just Quicken up the action of it coming
down does anyone have any ideas I love
working with Sarah and hearing her take
on the story and she could not have been
more supportive of my Explorations and
of my input from in the
feels talking telling August what
happened
this is day one but there will be
something
Kita was an enormous asset to the film
on every level and I think we were all
completely blown away by what she did
even though these women have a very
strict mode of dress they were minute
details in the way these women dress
which expressed their character you
would think given the look of the film
and the ethos of the community that the
costumes would be made from Cottons and
organic materials but these costumes are
made from practical fabric for a very
practical lifestyle as soon as all the
hair and the dress was on like the big
braids in the back like I felt so in it
I had my socks and sandals I had my
polyester dress that Kita made herself
the head scarves were put on very
specifically that level of precision in
terms of even patterning and the types
of fit it really made you feel like you
were having an authentic experience
everything about the film just came
together so beautifully we said that
this would now be the bar for work it
was such a wonderful collaboration we
hope we've been attacked by men
not by ghosts or Satan as we were led to
believe for so long we know that we've
not imagined these attacks that we were
made unconscious with cow tranquilizer
the conversation that these women have
in this Hayloft addresses the harm of
power imbalance and violence and
hierarchical structures we live in they
are dealing with ideas and Concepts and
the future and the past and who we are
and those things need to be discussed
and talked about and I think that's why
the film's so extraordinary is that she
never pulled back from it it is thought
provoking and it's poignant but most
importantly it is active we know that we
are bruised and infected and Pregnant
and terrified and insane and some of us
are dead
we know that we must protect our
children regardless of who is guilty
it's sort of an exercise in watching the
human experiment at work where you can
see people affect how other people think
you see people change their minds you
see people stay Resolute you see
emerging of Hope and I think most
essentially the scene asks the audience
what would you do
[Music]
please
foreign